jetzt komme gebastelt alter komme halt
dich fest ich weiß so das ihs komme das
für dich da raus leute herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video hat im
letzten zwei tage kein video kam heute
sind wir endlich wieder zurück und zwar
mit niemand geringerem als dem keyboard
wer von euch weiß was immer für gott
macht man sagt ihm murphy but what if i
was angela merkel und dann baute daraus
irgend foto und das machen wir heute
jetzt ich habe mega mega viele gute
ideen für foto mixturen ich möchte gerne
wissen
what if sturm waffe den hab ich nämlich
vor zwei tagen erst getroffen
richtig seltsam wolfsturm what if sturm
waffel lp wars kong crafter hdtv px drk
gut dass er weg ist der ansturm auf dem
bild ist einfach 3 lukas gesicht zweimal
in lukas gesicht und lukas ginsheimer im
hintergrund was er mir jetzt geliefert
hat ist meine lukas häppchen aber wo es
muss sturm auf in diesen dingen du
kleiner scheint wie du bist eigentlich
nicht mehr wie du wahrscheinlich scheint
dann auch das ep nicht verstanden wird
ob er zum anlass proteststurm waffe von
crafter
und sieht aus wie ein amerikanischer
kopf oder du würde ich mir
amerikanischen polizisten vorstellen
er hat halt hier so die sonnenbrille ja
aber die sonnenbrille hat keine bügel
wenn ihr guckt hier da ist nichts okay
ich habe es gesehen was er für bolt
macht jetzt bin ich bereit mein eigenes
gesicht in die ohne zu schmeißen
jhd usk sorgt die jetzt komme gebastelt
alter komme halt dich fest
ich weiß dass ich komme das für dich was
ist das von der hohen kreatur
was ist das für eine heldin kreatur was
soll das für gesicht sein nein nein nein
nein nein nein nein ein weg damit weg
damit ganz schnell eine gute idee
mister x games wie leute jetzt haltet
euch facchin fest sieht der ausschuss
hatte problem ist am morgen zu finden
gleich werde diese kombination einfach
zu hart für die welt vielleicht hat der
boss und eingebauten sicherheitsschutz
wenn die kombination zu hart sind wenn
ihr auch nicht zugelassen okay wir
prüfen was aber wie wär's mit word fsv
aus doch was ist das für eine lebensform
was auf eine sache nur noch ausbauen
ich will's wissen jfw wie post ag heute
bei x-factor was wäre passiert wenn
revier als frau geboren wäre und diese
forscher ist schon schlimm genug
die sache ist ich weiß nicht ob es
gesehen habt aber ich nehme das hier
gerade um viertel nach zwei nachts auf
wenn ich jetzt ein schlaf bekomme ich
albträume davon wie rewe und ag
fusioniert aussehen oder what if mister
x games
kg wie die antwort hat uns gar nicht
noch verwehrt doch ich lasse nicht nach
dem rummel der wissenschaft und er macht
sich ein blog zu blog sollte das ist
vielleicht in einer anderen folge denn
das war's von heute dank fühlst du schon
so weit rein macht's gut und 3 1 für
jeden der einen kommentar unter den
deutschen ein schöner